[Musique]
le soir les enfants bon choix
ce soir mes petits on danse lol lol lol
hollande d'accord nounours mais ne saute
pas comme ça tu vas faire chavirer notre
nuage tellement vu de ton seul patron
mon le seul lol lol buzz soir les
enfants ma parole mais vous avez fait le
ménage
on a tous bien entrer rémy tout haut et
fort nous ont beaucoup aidé du shérif
l'eau maman va être bien contents et
bien puisque vous êtes aussi sage on va
danser au sens élargi
attention en avant
moi je vais danger aujourd'hui avec les
petits je vais vous montrer
regardez on ne peut pas se tromper
renault la main et surtout tenons nous
bien d'abord on va tourner au delà de ce
côté mais gentiment sans bousculade e
puis on va s'arrêter à tire de l'autre
côté hommes ont fait une promenade à
kesha main et j'ai dit c'est ça vous
plaît tant mes enfants venez pas baisser
un petit tour par six veuves oudry et
c'est réussi
maintenant chantons tous en choeur en
avant les bons danseurs
bravo d'une ourse ce que je chante bien
bravo les enfants vous avez très bien
danser mais à présent c'est là d'aller
au lit les eaux sont ni semer de voeux
attention en avant mars
quel enfant est vivante et ne la jette à
la lune
fêtes de bourg nuit les enfants
allez vite vous coucher et soyez aussi
sage que nicolas pimprenelle et les
trois neveux nounours ils sont mis
l'ombre de voeux un patron ce sont des
oursons exemplaire de famille pas trop
allons en route gros nounours
exemplaires
dans une nuit des enfants fêtes de bourg
eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh